TUCKER CARLSON, COMING UP NEXT.
GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IT WOULD BE FUNNY TO DO A PULSE
ON TIME AND ASKED PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN WASHINGTON, D.C., HAVE
YOU EVER MET JOE BIDEN
PERSONALLY?
QUESTION MIKE I BET A
STRIKINGLY LARGE PERCENTAGE
WOULD SAY YES.
HE HAS BEEN IN WASHINGTON FOR IT
FOREVER.
HOW LONG?
HERE SOME PERSPECTIVE.
JOE BIDEN FIRST RAN FOR
PRESIDENT MORE THAN 30 YEARS
AGO.
DIDN'T GO WELL, TO PUT IT
MILDLY.
AT THE TIME, BIDEN WAS CAUGHT
STEALING DETAILS FROM ANOTHER
MAN'S BIOGRAPHY, NEIL CONNECT.
OF COURSE, HE DROPPED OUT IN A
HUMILIATING SCANDAL.
PEOPLE WHO KNEW HIM ALWAYS
THOUGHT HE WOULD TRY AGAIN FOR
THE PRESIDENCY AND OF COURSE, HE
IS.
THIS YEAR SEEMS A PRETTY STRANGE
TIME TO DO IT.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE A CANDIDATE
MORE OUT OF STEP WITH THE MOMENT
HE'S RUNNING.
BIDEN IS OLD AND PALE AND HIS
PARTY WORSHIPS YOUTH AND
DIVERSITY.
HE HAS SPENT DECADES
REPRESENTING AS A MODERATE AT A
TIME WHEN IS MARTY PARTY IS
MOVING HARD TO THE LEFT.
AS OF RIGHT NOW THOUGH, BIDEN IS
STILL THE FRONT RUNNER FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION BUT IS NOT
A COMFORTABLE FIT.
SO WHAT EXACTLY IS JOE BIDEN
RUNNING ON?
WELL YOU GUESSED, IDEAS, HAVE
ANOTHER THEORY, YOU'VE MOSTLY
HAD A FEW BEERS ALREADY.
IF YOU THINK THAT, NO, BIDEN IS
NOT RUNNING IT ON IDEAS,
INSIGHT, HE IS RUNNING ON
ELECTABILITY.
THE NOTION THAT ONLY HE, ONLY
JOE BIDEN, CAN BE DONALD TRUMP.
WE WILL LET BIDEN'S NEW CAMPAIGN
AT EXPLAIN.
WATCH.
>> WE KNOW IN OUR BONES OF THIS
ELECTION IS DIFFERENT.
THE STAKES ARE HIGHER.
THE THREAT IS MORE SERIOUS.
WE HAVE TO BE DONALD TRUMP AND
ALL THE POLES AGREE, JOE BIDEN I
ALL THE POLES AGREE, JOE BIDEN S
ALL THE POLES AGREE, JOE BIDEN T
ALL THE POLES AGREE, JOE BIDEN E
ALL THE POLES AGREE, JOE BIDEN S
ALL THE POLES AGREE, JOE BIDEN R
ALL THE POLES AGREE, JOE BIDEN N
ALL THE POLES AGREE, JOE BIDEN E
ALL THE POLES AGREE, JOE BIDEN T
DEMOCRAT TO DO THE JOB.
TO RESTORE THE SOUL OF THE
NATION BATTERED BY AN EROTIC
VICIOUS, BULLYING PRESIDENT
BIRDS DOG STRONG, STEADY, STABLE
RELATED LEADERSHIP.
>> GOT THAT?
STRONG, STEADY, STABLE.
NOW IT'S DODDERING, FLAKY,
WEIRD.
NO.
STRONG, STEADY, STABLE.
THAT'S JOE BIDEN
SELF-DESCRIPTION.
HE IS MOST EXPERIENCED CANDIDATE
IN THE RACE.
IN FACT, HE'S THE ONLY
VICE PRESIDENT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY WHO SERVED MORE THAN TWO
FULL TERMS IN OFFICE BEER THAT'S
HOW HE MET THE SURVIVORS OF THE
PARK WHEN SHOOTING AT THE
WHITE HOUSE JUST LAST YEAR.
LAST YEAR.
THE REST OF US ASSUMED ADVICE
MIKE PRINCE WAS THE
VICE PRESIDENT BUT NO.
WATCH.
>> I WATCH WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
THOSE KIDS IN PARKLAND WENT UP
TO SEE ME AND SOME OF YOU
COVERED IT.
>> Tucker: A GO.
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
YOU THOUGHT THAT PENANCE WAS THE
VP?
NOW.
BIDEN WAS STILL THE
VICE PRESIDENT AND NONE OF US
KNOW OF IT.
IT TURNS OUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS YOU DO KNOW ABOUT HIM.
FOR EXAMPLE, BIDEN'S
CONVENTIONAL BUT BIOGRAPHY, THE
WHEN HE CAN FIND ON WIKIPEDIA
CLAIMS HE WENT FROM A PRIVATE
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THENW
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THENI
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THENE
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THENS
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THENT
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THENO
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THENL
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THENW
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THENS
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THENH
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THENO
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND THEN.
HE GRADUATED-76 IN THE CLASS OF
85 STUDENTS BID THAT THE BIDEN
WE THOUGHT WE KNEW.
WHAT WE DIDN'T KNOW IS THAT
WHILE BECOMING AN ATTORNEY,
BIDEN WAS ALSO WORKING DEEP
UNDERGROUND.
LITERALLY UNDERGROUND AS A COAL
MINER.
STREAKED FACE AND HEAD LAMP
INCLUDE A PAIR THAT'S WHAT HE'S
CAUGHT SOMETIMES ALL THESE YEARS
LATER, MINING JUST TAKES IT OUT
OF THE MAN.
>> IT YOU MAY BE AGAINST ME BUT
I AM A HARD COALMINER.
ANTHRACITE SCHOOL, CURRENT
SCRANTON, PENNSYLVANIA, PAIR
THAT'S WHERE I WAS BORN AND
RAISED.
AND IT'S NICE TO BE BACK IN COAL
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE.
A COAL MINER.
IT'S TRUE.
YOU SHOULD ALSO KNOW THAT BIDEN
WAS ALSO AT VARIOUS TIMES OF
FIREMEN, HARD-BOILED HOMICIDE
DETECTOR, A GOLD MINER IN THE
UCONN, AND A WISE OLD INDIAN
CHIEF WHO SLAYED MANY OF THEIR
IN HIS DAY.
NOT YOUR AVERAGE POLITICIAN, FOR
SURE.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, BIDEN WAS ALSO
A WAR HERO.
OF COURSE HE WAS.
DON IN HIS GENERATIONS WAR.
NO.
AS THE OLDEST OLDEST AMERICAN
SOLDIER/U.S. SENATOR SERVING INI
SOLDIER/U.S. SENATOR SERVING INA
SOLDIER/U.S. SENATOR SERVING IN,
BRAVING LIMITLESS ENEMY FIRED TO
BRING DEMOCRACY TO THAT NATION
APPEARED WATCH.
>> NUMBER ONE, YOU TAKE ALL THE
TROOPS OUT, YOU BETTER HAVE
HELICOPTERS READY TO TAKE THOSE
3,000 CIVILIANS INSIDE THE GREEN
ZONE WHERE I HAVE BEEN SEVEN
TIMES AND SHOT AT.
>> Tucker: YEAH, HE'S BEEN
SHOT OUT.
OTHERS WE SHOULD TELL YOU
REMEMBER THAT MOMENT DIFFERENTLY
PAIR THEY CLAIM BIDEN WAS SIMPLY
STAYING AT A HOTEL IN IRAQ WHEN
A MORE EXPLODED HUNDRED YARDS
AWAY.
IT DIDN'T EVEN DELAY THE
BREAKFAST BUFFET BUT WHATEVER
APPEARED TO BIDEN, IT WAS
ANOTHER DEATH-DEFYING MOMENT IN
A LONG LIFE AT THE WORLD'S MOST
INTERESTING MONITOR.
LISTEN TO THE TIME HE NEARLY GOT
KILLED BY THE TRAVEL BAN.
>> IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHERE
AL QAEDA LIVES, YOU WANT TO KNOW
WHERE BIN LADEN IS, COME BACK TO
AFGHANISTAN WITH ME.
COME BACK TO THE AREA WHERE MY
HELICOPTER WAS FORCED DOWN AND
THE THREE-STAR GENERAL AND THREE
UNITED STATES SENATORS HAD
10,000 FEET IN THE MIDDLE OF
THOSE MOUNTAINS.
I CAN TELL YOU WHERE THEY ARE.
>> Tucker: I ONCE AGAIN, WE
MUST TRY TO, THERE WAS SOME
DISPUTE ABOUT WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED OTHER POSSIBLY MORE
FACTUALLY REALLY ARE A
RELIABLE CLAIM THAT BIDEN'S
HELICOPTER LANDED BECAUSE OF A
SNOWSTORM, NOT BECAUSE USAMA
BIN LADEN WAS PERSONALLY TRYING
TO MURDER BIDEN.
BUT DON'T TELL SENATOR BIDEN
THAT.
NOR SHOULD YOU TELL HIM THAT
NOBODY CAN REMEMBER SEEING HIM
AT ALL THOSE CIVIL RIGHTS
FITTINGS AND DEMONSTRATIONS HE
CLAIMED TO HAVE LEAD IN THE
1960s.
HE AND MARTIN LUTHER KING,
LEADERS OF THE MOVEMENT, THAT
WAS HIS STORY COULD HE'S GOT A
MILLION STORIES LIKE THAT AND
HE'S THE HERO OF EVERY SKILL ONE
OF THEM.
TAKE A SEAT AND HE WILL TELL YO
YOU.
AS YOU LISTEN, THIS MAN, THIS